so uh the one night he says to me mom um
he's a bit like a teenager at this point
mum yeah you
book it so i can do anything i said yes
milo you can if you put your
if you put your minds or something and
you find something you love and you want
to work hard you can do
anything you want to do and he's like
well that's not true is it
oh no uh well uh well
what do you mean he says well that's not
true because what i want to do
is i want to take a koala home from the
zoo bring it here and keep it as a pet i
can't do that
he's very literal and through my head
i'm going
cat dealies kid kidnaps koala and kills
it from you
no no no no know you can't do that you
can't see that i said but what you can
do and you know in those
and i'm sure we've all had those moments
where you know when they ask you
something
and your brain is like racing trying to
find the right answer and you can almost
hear your brain
work and it's like
[Music]
it's always like a drum roll for when
you come up with the answer
and you're going as fast as you can and
i said no molly you absolutely can't do
that i said but what you can do
is if you go to school and you study
really hard
and maybe you might study something
called biology and then you can
study something called zoology and go to
university then
you could be in charge of all the koalas
at the zoo
or you could even travel to the other
side of the planet which is as far as
you can get to australia which is where
koalas come from
and you could go to a sanctuary and you
could help koalas who don't have a mom
and dad
and i just and i left it like that and i
was
in my head i was like high-fiving myself
and all the rest of it he just looked at
me like that
he's like not the same all right mom all
right mom
i guess i'll accept that answer
how you twisted that was really really
[Music]
nice
you